your kids are designing your because you
tour a lot yes or around you do shows
your kids are designing your tour
posters they're actually making them yes
I mean well we don't have a yard I live
in New York City so I I have to give
them some jobs right I mean there's just
so I have them draw these tour posters
and I pretend to pay them you know six
or seven they don't know currency I'm
like this direct deposit it's going in
there I'll give them five bucks but like
they you know and you know the posters
are pretty good all right let's see one
I think who did this one that we have we
have a show so I think this is Mikey did
this one by the way Michael is 37 years
old joke in the world all right no but
Michael did this what is this the one
worried look at the top it says it's
just a show yeah that is that is
promising the leaked show business is
all about promising a lot up front it's
just a show it's not it's not an
endorsement necessarily yeah but I don't
know what was going on back in the
picture there's people peering in for a
balloon I thought those were severed
heads on a show I thought those were a
game of Thrones severed heads on a show
it's like the girl has no personality
whatever that is but ya know so much of
the art that my children do could really
end me up in jail yeah let's look at
this next one one of your children did
this yeah this is Patrick this weekend
Irving Texas yes they'll ask me if I
they can do a poster for money and I'll
write on a post-it note the names of the
cities and that one was curving Texas
Las Vegas and Long Beach and Patrick
didn't include Vegas and he also he
likes marshmallow so marshmallow was not
on the show marshmallow the
yeah and then I don't know people going
will think marshmallow the club DJ is
gonna be at your show he's opening for
me but you know what's amazing you look
at that and it's like I you know like I
get these posters I don't know what he's
trying to say I don't know if that was
like a Christmas tree or that's just
like this scribbling of a madman
yeah right let's just let's get to this
one cuz this one disturbed me a bit that
looks like that looks like Jason Jason
mask and he's saying you killed my mom
how does that have to do anything with
your comedy show I don't know I think
and and by the way there's a big Jason
Voorhees my two younger six and seven
big Jason Voorhees fans and they've
never seen Friday the 13th and we
haven't seen it they haven't seen it how
do they know I'm lacking as a dad I
should show but no they've seen they
know about it from a video game roblox
and you'd think that I would be like all
right well I got to investigate this
thing where there's serial killers but
I'm like okay that's good enough so I
don't know what is going on with roblox
but it's teaching my children about
serial killers my daughter the other day
told me all my friends joke about how
you look like Slenderman well I get told
that murderer I get told that look like
Sano's or whatever so
there's so much you know like being a
debt like the crap I take from my kids
it's unbelievable like when I was
growing up I was terrified my dad did
nothing my dad never went to a
parent-teacher conference
I don't think my dad even knew I went to
school my father couldn't be bothered to
like turn his head if something was
happening behind him like what the
hell's going on back there
I don't know if he couldn't turn his
head or if it just wasn't worth the
effort right we're celebrating my
birthday
[Laughter]
[Applause]